okay hi everyone next part of the the
session is going to be a fundraising
panel where we have three ladies from
the Seattle scene who is going to impart
some advice on how they've they've
approached fundraising and and some of
the lessons that they've learned my name
is Kirsty Nathu I'm one of the partners
at Y Combinator I'm the CFO there so I
look after all of the finances for both
YC internally and also helping founders
with raising money looking at cap tables
understanding dilution so seen seen a
lot and seen seen a lot of if things
happen during fundraising just to give
you a couple of stats in 2017 only 2% of
VC funding went to all female founding
teams and only 12% went to mix gender
teams so there's a lot of work to be
done there and we hope that the you
ladies in the audience can help to
change that trend and really get those
numbers up in the future so I'm going to
pass over to the ladies now what they'll
do a much better job of introducing
themselves so each of you if you want to
just explain a little bit about your
company who you are and how much you've
raised so far hi thanks Christy here so
I'm Beth Kolko and I am the founder
co-founder of shift labs which is a
medical device company here in Seattle
and I started the company after being a
professor for many years including at
u-dub and we have raised a total of uh
well 1.7 million of dilutive and then a
$300,000 grant so just about two million
dollars which for a med tech company is
not a lot and we have a product that's
on the market and approved in the US as
well as Europe and a few other places so
that's what I do is what I have been
doing and fundraising is well I will
just say this when I told my partner
what I was doing he said you know don't
take this the wrong way honey but you
know you've done a lot of things really
well but they do know that fundraising
has been the hardest thing for you right
I'm like yeah it has
so maybe that's why I'm here my name is
Amy Nelson and I'm the founder and CEO
of the Riveter and we're really excited
to host the conference today and to have
all of you here um we launched our this
base our first base in May the Riveter
is female forward workspaces and
community for business and impact we
launched our second space in September
and we have raised a proceed last spring
of seven hundred and twenty thousand and
then we're about halfway through a seed
round right now so in an interesting
position to be on this panel
kind of in the middle of everything but
a fundraising is hard but it's necessary
and it's important to learn how to do it
and how to do it well and so I'm happy
that we can all be up here to tell our
stories and that's small a piece of that
hi everybody I just want to say that
I've never seen this space look more
beautiful than today and I've seen it
before but it looks amazing you are all
incredibly beautiful how many people
here are in the process of starting a
company or have started a company
awesome
Congrats and we are here for you and
each other my name is Kristen Hamilton I
am the CEO and co-founder of karu we do
predictive hiring so we're helping
employers choose the right talent using
machine learning and AI and ultimately
leveling the playing field to provide
access to opportunity for people based
on things like what they can do instead
of where they went to school
I've we've raised 15,000 16,000 dollars
so
a little more we've raised we've raised
15 million dollars in three rounds and
this company the there's a story in each
round but I'm guessing we're gonna get
to that I once dad I'd like to share
that someone shared with me that was
daunting but interesting they said
you're more likely to get struck by
lightning than to raise for them to get
a term sheet from a Silicon Valley
venture investor city told me that when
I was in the process of fund raising so
I just want to be here to say that it's
all possible despite the odds and
getting more and more possible so this
is gonna be good we have a lot of
different perspectives here so first of
all let's talk a little bit about where
where the money came from did you raise
money from people here in Seattle or did
you have to go further afield and if you
did go further afield did you see any
real differences in the the different
geographic locations that made you have
to change your approach so we raised we
went through we went through YC in
winter 15 and before that we had done a
small incubator here in Seattle for a
kind of social conscious companies
called fledge we did a kind of small we
raised a little bit of money mostly
friends and family kind of stuff before
we got into YC most of our money who was
raised as a result of Y C's demo day and
I gotta be completely honest about that
so med tech is pretty traditional in
terms of investment least med devices
and our team didn't come from that
background that was sort of part of our
super power in terms of thinking about
the product but it made fundraising
really challenging so what worked for us
was to tap into people's optimism and
desire to change the world and so they
advised the investors who really came
into that first seed round after demo
day were people who believed in the
vision and also were willing to think
not just about the US but globally and
so most of those investors came from
California came from Silicon Valley some
came from other parts
the world as well some institutional but
a lot of angels and so they just they it
it seemed like they had more appetite
for risk and they'd they were surrounded
by more risky things and so they were
willing to look at us and say hey why
not so that was a big difference future
fundraising activities similar to where
you're at is um you know now we're at a
different position and now we actually
are reaching out into that medtech
community which again asks is not is
interested in risk and has different
kinds of metrics and so it's about
adapting to that so we definitely see
differences geographically as well as
based on what people's backgrounds are
um I talked about in the angel round
that we raised and then how I've I have
approached raising the seed round an
angel round that we raised
we raised on a safe so and it's an
important kind of precursor to going out
to raise is deciding the vehicle on
which you will raise which is something
I had to learn about I was a lawyer for
ten years so it was you know brand-new
to all of this when I started this a
year ago so we decided on the vehicle we
would raise on and then I kind of
stumbled into my first angel investors
by attending events so I went to startup
week and I raised my hand I think you
were on the panel I was that was at the
mompreneur panel yes and I raised my
hand and asked a question and prefaced
it by talking about my business because
I would say that is the one thing you
have to talk about what you're doing to
everyone because you never know who
you're talking to so you know I raised
my hand and asked a question about the
business and afterward a woman came up
to me and asked me some questions about
it I ended up pitching her and she
became my first investor my second
investor I was in my daughter's co-op
preschool class talking to another
mother who I barely knew about what I
was doing and she said you should talk
to my husband he's a serial entrepreneur
he became my second investor and then
introduced me to my third and fourth
investors and so for me that was really
a lesson and you you don't know you know
who who does angel investing and who you
know who you're talking to who might be
interested in your business on the flip
side I then went ahead after those kind
of instances I went ahead and made a
list of people in my network or
people I wanted to invest and then for
the people I wanted to invest I found
connections to them
I was super methodical about it you know
spreadsheet going on LinkedIn I want to
connect to person X who can introduce me
asking the people to introduce me and
seeking out those really warm
connections which I think is massively
helpful in fundraising which makes sense
because you know it's easier to say yes
to taking the time to listen to someone
or listen to an idea if you have an
introduction from a trusted person and
then the final piece I guess about the
angel investing piece that I learned a
lot in the precede round is that that
early in a company and I was raising
money when the Riveter was just an idea
that I had you know I had a deck and an
idea and myself and angel investors and
early early investors are largely
investing in the founder and what they
think if they think you can pull it off
and so you have to be really confident
that you can and project that and
present that every way that you can with
the VCS and approaching the seed round I
at the beginning I don't think I was
incredibly organized about how I would
go out and do it and then I realized
what I needed to do was put together a
full deck which I didn't want to do it
because it's like a high school project
like oh I have to sit down and write all
the slides and but it's really really
important because it's what people will
look at when they're you know being
introduced to your business and thinking
about it so made a deck and then I sat
down and I made a long list of VCS that
I wanted to talk to and then once again
I figured out a way to get warm
introductions which it took a lot of
time I completely underestimated how
much of my time as the CEO would go to
fundraising in the early days but that's
that's kind of and then I've gone
geographically all over the country both
times so just in terms of where our
investors come from they come from
Seattle they come from San Francisco Los
Angeles New York Boston everywhere which
is everywhere the riveter will be so
yeah when we were on the mompreneur
panel I asked when the dad preneur panel
was going to
so I've raised money in seven different
rounds of venture and that one one
failed so seven plus one failed that
plus upon IPO so scattered
geographically everywhere I would say
and my learning has been to generalize
and stereotype Silicon Valley investors
are the most risk tolerant and do the
least due diligence and so they have
they have had so many more reps you know
it's just about learning right then
most of them many of them have been
other cities so that city has just that
environment has just seen so many more
iterations it's it's definitely a unique
environment and then Seattle is emerging
my first company was started in Seattle
we did not raise any money from Seattle
other than some angels who jumped in
after we had a term sheet but it's
definitely emerging they just haven't
been that many venture capital funds in
Seattle and I think that it has been
initially maybe more of a follower but
it's really exciting to see what's
happening now in Seattle because there's
an increasing number of venture funds
and more dollars in Seattle and the
nature of Seattle's history and tech has
been more enterprise and b2b so
therefore you know raising money for a
consumer business in Seattle was a
little bit harder and again that's
evolving so there's differences in
nuances I think geographically New York
investors are financial investors and
they do a lot of due diligence they ask
me questions I had never been asked
before that would make people in Silicon
Valley roll their eyes so it's really
interesting but I think the
differentiator about the fundraising I
have experienced is more relevant from
early when you haven't raised money
before versus late when you've raised it
before so a good friend of mine is the
CEO of procom he said that christen we
know who's going to lead our next round
we don't
who it's going to be but we know that
person we have a relationship with the
person who's going to race who's going
to lead our next round and it was a
really interesting thing that he said
because I thought yeah that's right it's
not I'm not gonna go to a stranger at
this point because we have relationships
but that first round that first time you
know it was like beg borrow steal and I
was also 28 years old so you know it was
really really hard and so to me that's
just the the difference is is
geographical to some extent as I
described but I think it's different
strategies depending on where you are
yourself in your fundraising evolution
and then also obviously where you are in
your company of course as well so how
does in terms of that strategy how does
it work even if you're raising you know
a seed round or a pre seed round or
whatever you want to call it everybody
calls things differently you know even
even that's early early first money
you're talking to a combination of
individuals and to institutional
investors of one form or another
how do you do you change your approach
or do you do talk differently to each of
those sets of people how is that how
does that work I guess I I have thoughts
on this and being kind of in the middle
of it I am so I have a background in
political fundraising because I was able
to go out and raise kin money for
candidates I believed in which has been
very helpful in this and I think the
main difference that I've had to learn
between raising from individuals and
raising from institutions is that it is
less of a conversation when you're
talking to institutions I think I when I
started I kind of went in more
conversational how I am you know just me
and I realized I kind of said I took
back after a first you sat back after
first few pitches and thought you know I
I used to be a litigator and I know what
going into a meeting like that is and
being very professional and talking
about a deal and I needed to go in and
say this is my business
this is an opportunity I'm giving to you
to join something I am building that
will show incredible returns is a great
business and I'm a really good CEO and
this is the deal and I'd love for you to
join me and that's it and I think taking
that approach has worked a lot better
for me it doesn't feel entirely natural
it's not how I approach confer
stations with people every day but this
is this is a business conversation and
to present it as such and then also I've
learned the more the further I've gotten
into this and like I only have nine
months of experience in this so I am NOT
an expert but you have to nail the
numbers you need to know your numbers
inside and out you need to know the
model that you built why you put those
assumptions and how things can change if
you don't you know if say there was a
downturn how would it change this or X
or Y but you really need to know your
numbers you come across as much more
knowledgeable about your business and
you do actually know your business
better when you know the numbers and I
think that's something that we don't
talk about enough but that really really
knowing the numbers that you're
presenting inside and out is so critical
yeah that's that's definitely a sad fact
really when when when out fundraising
that women are held to a higher standard
in that and really knowing in numbers
inside out is absolutely crucial because
as soon as you start wavering you lose
the confidence of the investors I'm
gonna just add something as someone who
came to fundraise doing very little
relevant experience so I've been a
professor right I know how to teach a
class but that was pretty much it turns
out I didn't know how to build a medical
device but so I didn't have a list of
people to go to I'm in a second this
spreadsheet warm intros LinkedIn anyone
who knows me knows how much I hate
social media but LinkedIn is my best
friend
I spend a tremendous amount of time
looking for those looking for those warm
intros that can be made but when we
first worked on raising it we did it for
years I mean years talking to everyone
the first check came from a friend who
had a company and had gave us like their
supply closet basically turned it into
an office for us and he just saw us
working every day for years on end and
saw the terrible things that were
happening you know all the typical
stories you hear about investors they
all happened and he just watched us go
through it and he saw how dedicated we
were and that's that's where the first
check came from but my co-founder Knight
we didn't know anybody with money we
didn't have any family with money we
don't have any friends with money well
turns out we did have one but you know
so I guess I what I want to say is even
when you're new at it and you
have it that existing network
perseverance is that's what you need
that's really all you need is that
perseverance story one quick story the
first ever check that was written was by
the guy had worked for for my first job
after college so I was a consultant and
he was the partner who started this
consulting firm for tech companies and I
you know killed myself for him I was
really I worked at sleep under the desk
and so forth and he and I was getting I
was an immigrant so I got a green card
through him and and actually that was a
huge deal because I was essentially a
prisoner in this company so I really
don't have a choice so I was I I really
did I but I was a person that made his
life okay because he didn't have to
sleep under the desk so I did that for
four years or something and then fast
forward I start this company with this
guy I went to college with and were like
here's our idea and he was and I went
his office with Glenn and we sat there
and I'll never forget he hand wrote the
check for $25,000 and he slid it across
the desk and he said don't lose my money
okay I was terrified actually I have a I
can't I really am the most responsible
with I can't stand the idea of losing
someone's money it's like Canadian
puritanical work ethic thing but I would
say that the lesson is that and that is
the first person that will write you a
check is the person who knows you I
think to the point of viewer in their
supply closet or I was you know sleeping
under the desk to make his life better
so he saw what I was capable of and they
invested in they'll invest in you as
opposed to necessarily your company and
it's funny now I do some angel investing
and I invest in people you know people I
know really well and when they're
starting something it's sort of almost
doesn't matter what they're starting is
I know them that well so I think a lot
of angels to actually think about it
that way and I one quick thing to add to
this because we've talked about LinkedIn
a lot for warm introductions you might
kill me for saying this but like Kristen
ovni Kieran who you will hear from later
they have all made introductions for me
and that's what your community will do
for you you are a female founder or this
tribe will help you you just have to ask
so I think it's been made fairly clear
here that fundraising is pretty hard
it's a long process and it has ups and
downs so how how have you learned to
cope with the lows of it and what
support networks have you been able to
leverage through that okay so I'm gonna
I'm gonna tell my nightmare story I
won't tell that the nitty-gritty details
but there was a horrible thing that
happened just an investor was completely
inappropriate and it was in a Starbucks
on Mercer Island so it was really public
and I couldn't even get outraged and
then and I had to go then I had to take
the bus home afterwards and and so I'd
kept my composure in front of him and
then I got on the bus and I'm sobbing
and I'm just texting everyone I know
like is this normal this person said
these things and they're like no it's
not normal and the next day I walked in
and my my co-founder I was telling him
about it and I'd been texting with him
and he said I want you to write it down
just write it all down right now write
the story down and it was sort of this
purging thing but basically your network
I mean the people who support you in
everything else in your life they will
support you through through the lows
because there will be there will be lows
I mean there's no way around it everyone
men and women fundraising is really hard
but it's also crucial
I'd say other than a lot of red wine my
co-founder because there's nobody else
to party process with in that way like
we go to the party which was not really
a party we have the pitch and then we
process and we process it to death and
we wonder about the you know body
language in the room and whatever so for
me I've never actually I'm a co-founder
I'm not a founder I mean I'm just in my
core I think I just prefer to co-found
things and so it's a team and that for
me has been my saving grace it you know
there are days I do well it processing
in days I don't I think for me that's
knowing expectation is really important
that I'm going to here know all of the
time until I hear yes and
accepting that and knowing that it's
absolutely not personal even though it
can feel like it changes the bar for me
I I am on my own pitching largely which
is somewhat different but I rely on my
team a ton to talk through things with
me to prepare me to bounce things off of
I talked to my family about it a lot too
because probably they wish I wouldn't
but I do and it's it's good and you know
I just I take time out to exercise which
is really important for me in my own
mental health and because you can let
this consume you 24 hours a day and you
should give yourself an hour right you
should give yourself an hour a day I
think that's really important and you're
going to hear horrible things you're
going to hear things that people
wouldn't say to men but it's really
equally as hard for men and women in
terms of the number of investors you're
gonna have to pitch to before you hear
yes so just a good attitude it was
really important and red white okay so
we just have a couple of minutes left so
I guess for each of you is there
anything that you wished you'd known
when you were starting that you can you
can share with with the audience here so
that when they go off to do their
fundraising they've got that piece of
advice in their mind so there was a time
with my company where I was working to
raise so essentially for medtech you
know we raised this money to build a
device it's really expensive to
commercialize devices
I should have raised more money to
commercialize it and I didn't and I
started and it was hard and I was like
oh I'd rather just talk to our customers
because they love me and and that's what
I did I let myself stop doing the hard
thing and then I did the comfortable
thing which was all work on sales cuz I
love doing that and you know that's
where I get the positive feedback and
it's not where I'm getting the
relentless nose and that was a mistake
I should have stuck with the hard thing
now that would have been better for the
future for the growth trajectory of our
company so don't be afraid of the hard
things I think for me it would be as I
was going out to raise the seed I wish I
had said I am going to start raising the
seed on this day
and at that time I will have my deck
ready I will have my list of VCs I want
to approach ready and I will just go and
do it and I kind of dragged the process
out a little bit on the front end of not
having everything prepared and starting
to talk to people and I think every time
I go forward I'll have my list of people
I'm reaching out to the dates I'm going
to fundraise like you make a business
plan and make a fundraising plan I think
that's the best way to put it I'm gonna
give you something very tactical that I
didn't do before and I started doing in
this company which has been incredibly
helpful so the first few times you pitch
you're terrible and some pie so they say
go with the you know that's the right
way to say this they'll let the VCS that
seem like your least favorite Mary or
the less you know impressive I know you
want to have some reps so don't have
those reps with an investor the only
other person fundraising process is an
unfair equation because as entrepreneurs
we raise I've raised seven rounds of
venture that's a lot in a career mostly
you raised two or three right one and in
venture capitalists are in doing many
many more deals than that
so they've seen the picture before so
the only other person who can really
give you good feedback other than an
investor is a CEO who's raised money so
what I started to do is I do this like
but I don't name four but all in one day
I ask my friends who are founders who
have raised money successfully to come
for 45-minute junks and we pitched them
and we get in a room and there's no like
you know pretending it we they're an
investor and we are pitching them and we
go for 20 minutes or whatever and then
we get feedback for whatever those the
rest of the time is and they're like
relentless you know which is exactly
it's a gift that feedback is a gift so
we did that and in one day we pitched
whatever for CEOs who had raised a ton
of money and sold companies to Google
and like that value was so incredible so
find ways to do that I would just highly
recommend it and then think about that
feedback it once you start actually
pitching investors the best you're not
gonna get a yes on your first pitch but
you are gonna get feedback so that's
your goal your goal is to get that
feedback
and when you call them you don't say are
you gonna you know invest you say I
really want your feedback and they'll
actually respond better to that and you
really want to write it down and think
about it and ask people if it seems like
good feedback and weighed against the
feedback you get next time which is
completely the opposite of what they
said but really I mean keep it really
notes on your feedback because some
people don't learn as they go through
the process and each round is a learning
process even though you've raised before
so you have to just really think of
yourself as a beginner all the time okay
well I can actually talk about this for
hours but sadly we've we've run out of
time so thank you very much to the three
of you for for sharing that knowledge
and giving that advice and I'm hoping
that that for you now who are thinking
about starting startups and going out
and raising that you have some some
really helpful information there so yeah
thank you again
[Music]
[Applause]
you